I was just quite curious actually what
have you made about the whole King
Charles Saga particularly with the
cancer
diagnosis yeah no I'm so sad to hear it
I just feel like you know King Charles
waited his whole life to ascend to the
throne and now within the first what six
months or so he gets this bad news and
while everybody's hoping it's a good
prognosis and that this will resolve
favorably it's just you know I'm sure he
wishes he didn't have to deal with this
crisis so soon into his tenure in the
job he's waited his entire life for um
look I'd love to end this by saying
something really sweet about Harry
getting on the plane to come out to be
with his dad I don't feel that way I
feel like there's no one who's done more
to upset the king than those two same
with the queen before she died the same
if you looked at who's caused them the
most upset and consternation and stress
in the year leading up to the Queen's
death and now in the year leading up to
the king's diagnosis it's that pair so I
think Better Off In Mono because I can't
help but wonder whether he got on that
plane and immediately leaked it to the
press for the publicity of it I just
don't think if he really cared about his
father he would have treated him the way
he's treated him over the past five
years it's been abominable I know that's
not a charitable take but that's how I
feel Megan you know it's funny before we
sat down Francis said to me do you think
I should ask Megan about the Royals and
I was like I don't know I mean I'm glad
he asked
we'll leave it